Janet Jackson may have split from her  billionaire husband with some Alanna  just three months after giving birth but  apparently miss Jackson is doing just  fine  a source close to the Jackson family  tells ET her focus right now is for son  Issa quote Jana is ecstatic  she's so happy with her baby and that's  all she is focused on a source tells us  that during the marriage quote janet was  very rarely seen leaving the house she  shared with Wissam a team of staff seem  to tend to all of her needs this  included two drivers a housekeeper her  own PA a nanny and more an eyewitness  says he believes Jana is now living with  her son minutes away from with Psalms  House  [Music]